Hey guys, and welcome to a money making
video. Now, this one is going to be
quite a bit different. It's going to be
a bit like my advanced flipping guide,
but for money making. I'm going to be
showing you how to find your own
methods. Kind of something people have
been uh well, ragging on me a bit is the
fact that when I publish a money making
method, it it does ruin it. Now,
temporarily, I would argue and not as
badly as most people are saying. They
kind of feel like the world's ending. Uh
but, I don't think that is 100% fair.
Either way, um what I'm going to be
showing you today is how I find my own
money making methods. It's not really
difficult, or I'm not really actually
that smart. I'm just going on a couple
of resources and stick to a couple
categories in where I find the money
making methods. Those are uh buying from
NPC shops. So, I buy from uh well, just
like uh vegetable stalls and [__] like
that. Uh lots of different things. Um I
also transform items. Now, that's a big
one. Uh
making armor sets,
uh repairing barrows armor,
uh dismantling Zulrah drops. Those are
all kind of item repair or sorry, uh
transforming an item.
It's a big category, so we're going to
break that down a little bit more for
you. And a couple others like opening
chests and uh just general updates that
kind of cause uh well, money making
methods to be available. Anyway, I hope
you are going to enjoy the video and uh
stick around to the end cuz we are going
to be giving away the uh bond from the
winner from one of my videos. Apologies
for the delay there. Anyway, long ass
intro, let's get started. Enjoy.
All right. So, we'll do start off with
one of the big categories of money
makers that I have uh released on my
channel. Uh
the secret is
NPC shops. Anywhere we can buy an item
from a non-player character or any
storefront, anything like that is uh
large portion of the time where a lot of
my money makers come from and some of
the better more consistent ones as well.
Uh so this is what I do. Uh it's really
not that skill for anything. I just open
up the wiki. So all I really search for
is NPC shops Old School RuneScape. Now
it's going to come up with a list of
shops in the game and there's a lot of
them
and not all of them are free to play,
but all I do is kind of look here, start
diving into the shops. So let's say um
well the Herblore shop.
And so now list five Herblore shops. All
these are pay to play just so you know.
And
um well let's go to the one in Taverley
cuz it's easier to get to. And then it
just shows you the shop and there's a
convenient thing in the wiki where it'll
show you all the price it sold at and
the price it sold at the Grand Exchange.
Uh so it's really easy to see what a
margin you can get from it. Just from
looking quickly the pestle and mortar
actually looks really good. Uh 632 they
would sell for in the GE and uh they
have
they sell it for and they have three in
stock. Next up what I would do is have a
look at the pestle and mortar in uh GE
tracker
um just to see what the accurate prices
are. And now I have it open up here
already. Uh if we go down to the month
looks like there's about 1,000 sold a
day or something like that. Uh which is
not too bad honestly for an item like
this and this could be done at a very
low level. Anyway let's go give it a
try.
Uh I just kind of randomly thought of
that a second ago. So let's only need
like uh well 1K.
And uh you possibly may need to be done
um
the Herblore quest that unlocks the
Herblore, but
uh I'm not 100% sure. I'm going to put
our house in Taverley and run there I
believe would be the easiest way. I've
got some house tabs.
Yes, we have seven house tabs. That'll
be enough.
And uh yeah we'll teleport to our house
and just give this a try. So we'll just
do this for a couple of seconds just to
give uh kind of show you the point at
least. And then we'll just run south
here.
Should be down here. Yep, just in here.
And now another feature that they put
into the game just yesterday or uh today
I guess, which makes this a lot easier,
is now that your your PIN will stay
unlocked for up to 5 minutes on uh world
hop or anything like that. So, yep, has
three in stock, seems accurate to me.
Um if you examine it as well, it'll show
you the price in the Grand Exchange. Uh
looks like about 591, so we just buy
those all out.
Hop worlds.
And uh we'll just keep doing this till
we are done. Okay, so we uh quickly did
uh two inventories of this. This should
just be our last inventory here. Where
is the guy over here? And uh that took
just like a couple minutes. And uh we'll
head back to our uh house to then to the
Grand Exchange. Um so we can go just see
how much we'd make off of all this.
Probably take like 5 minutes or
something, maybe a little bit more.
And uh we'll see how many pestles and
mortar mortars we managed to get. 52,
I think. Say already had one.
And if we go back to the Grand Exchange.
All right, we're back to the Grand
Exchange and we will sell off our port
pestles and mortar. God, that's hard to
say. And we'll just dump one now and
what how I usually do it. Just dump one,
see what we can actually uh get all of
them sold for roughly. Uh looks like
they didn't sell for 516. We'll lower it
even more.
Just see what they insta sell for.
515. Uh that's fine. We'll just sell
this for 515.
Probably could get more,
uh but we sold most of them already and
we'll get about 26K. Uh so that only
took 5 minutes, 26K
times six, uh 312K. So, I mean
is this the best money making method?
Probably not, but the fact it only took
me 5 minutes to find this, didn't take
long. Uh it was pretty much the first
NPC shop I clicked on, uh makes it
pretty profitable and easy for anyone to
just go look through the wiki and find
profitable money makers without trying
too hard honestly. So, NPC shops one of
my more favorite ways to make money in
Old School Runescape. Now, moving on to
one of the biggest and my most favorite
category is transforming items. Now,
this one's a little bit harder to get
the hang of because there's not really a
rule or a list of
items that you can do. You just kind of
have to find them for yourself and you
get a sense for what items might work
for this type of money making method.
So, again, one way I do this is just by
starting and looking at the wiki.
Uh so, yeah, I just searched up the
wiki. Okay, the imbued hearts here.
Let's have a look at that. Uh let's see
how you get the imbued heart. Uh dropped
from a superior slayer monster. That we
can't really manufacture, so we're not
going to do that. Uh
toxic blowpipe.
And then you just read about the item.
So, the toxic blowpipe is a two-handed
weapon that it requires 75 range to
wield. It is made by using a chisel on a
tanzanite fang. Okay. So, this item is
being transformed using a chisel on it.
You require 53 fletching to do it. Uh
which we do have.
And uh venom venom venom. Okay, so one
thing you could try here is turning
tanzanite fangs into toxic blowpipes,
which I have done in the past. Let's
have a look more here. Uh the toxic
blowpipe is charged with zulrah scales.
It cannot be equipped in this uncharged
except when fully degraded while
equipped. Uh so, you can charge up the
zulrah scales. This one actually has two
ways you can transform it. Let's have a
look at G tracker here.
Start with the tanzanite fang.
And uh
toxic blowpipe.
Uh so, the tanzanite fang can be turned
directly into the toxic blowpipe, which
makes it an easy to make a comparison.
Uh so, we come down here to the day
graph to get the most recent price. Uh
well, let's see, about uh 2 4
4 4. 2 4 4 5. And uh it's going to sell
uh for about the same. So I wouldn't
recommend doing this.
Another thing we could look at is again
charging it. So an uncharged Tanzanite
fang versus a or not uncharged blowpipe
versus a full blowpipe.
Empty and I guess you can't sell a full
blowpipe.
Okay, well looks like you can't sell
that. Moving on to something else, let's
have a look at the Wiki more.
Uh well let's just look at the dragon
dagger.
Uh well dragon dagger P++
dragon dagger
look here.
Uh dragon dagger also referred to as a D
or DDS DDS++
Uh can be put super poison on it. So if
you look at well then you'd look at the
price of dragon daggers
super poison or P++ poison and then see
if there's a margin there.
Now that is one thing you can do. You
can just scour the Wiki, look for items.
I do this a lot. Well here we got the
onyx amulet.
Um requires a gold bar and an onyx
crate. Now this one I learned about
through GE tracker. Of course I don't
have the level 90 crafting to do this.
So keep in mind that there are skill
requirements to do this sometimes.
Speaking of that, GE tracker does have a
very useful tool to side here if you do
have the premium membership which I
honestly would pay for this exclusively
just to have this bit here. Uh money
making under that is item sets and
crafting. Now this part is really
extremely useful. It'll show you a bunch
of different ways that items are
transformed or crafted or made into sets
and display the most profitable ones
here.
Uh so a brim's armor set one thing I've
done quite a few times. I have
successfully combined 10 of these
easily. So that'd be about three 4 mil
right there.
Uh onyx amulet like I was telling you
about. It even shows you what you need
onyx and the gold bar. Be nice if they
had the skill requirements there but I
can't ask for anything everything.
Uh malediction wards, something I've
done in the past. Eternal boots, need 75
crafting or room crafting, I think, to
make these.
Uh, more armor combinations, but they
have a load of good stuff here.
And let me just pick one out that I
think might work here. Let's do the
Ahrim's set.
Um, so a few of you have seen me do this
in the past, but I I'll do it again
anyway.
Uh, so it looks like you can sell these
set for about
Well, this might not be super accurate
just because of the price here.
Yeah, so we're going to sell the price
or for about 41.
And maybe 4260
or something. So, you have to take into
account sometimes there is a huge price
variance, which might add up to um, the
price or the item not actually being
profitable. Let's maybe not do that. May
I have a load it's um,
uh, the book of law page set. Another
thing I've done in the past and is a
transformable item. How you do this is
the page set is the combination of four
different pages, the Armadyl page one,
two, three, and four. Now, GE Trackers
is displaying a profit of 71K here. Of
course, you don't need this. You can
figure this out on your own, but it's a
good to list of ideas. So, I'm just
going to look at the prices of all of
the Armadyl pages here.
Uh, now I haven't done this before. I
know that the pages tend to buy pretty
quickly, uh, but the page sets sell a
bit slower.
And I will just put these all down to
the day graph here.
So, again, you want to look at the
actual page set here. And it looks
pretty in line with what the price has
been over the last day. So, we'll go
ahead and do this. I'll put an offer in
for each of these here.
Uh, so the page one we'll try for about
300K.
And the limit on these are five, so we
might need a little bit more money
possibly. Maybe not. Also, Armadyl page
one.
And we're going to try buying that for
Oh, about let's try 305K. Or 308 just to
match the
actual trade price there.
308 do we buy any? Yeah, we got one
right at the bat. Nice.
Armadyl
page two.
And if you don't have access to GE
tracker, you can use OSBuddy exchange or
just sign up for the free version of GE
tracker. You won't have access to the
day graph,
but you should still be able to make a
rough guess
what the prices should be like or just
price check the item if you like.
Armadyl page two, we're going to try for
about 402.
And do the five of those as well.
And we'll go for the Armadyl page three
next.
Armadyl page three, we'll try for about
310k.
And five of those.
And last up the Armadyl page four.
Armadyl page four, we'll try buying for
about 495.
And that's about it guys. We'll come
back once these have bought and we'll
combine them for you and I'll show you
the results. All right, there we go. All
the pages have come through. Five
Armadyl page ones.
Five Armadyl pages two.
Page threes and page fours we increased
price and kind of instantly bought them.
For this set combination we're going to
go to sets.
And then should be down at the bottom
somewhere here. Book of law page sets.
Now all you have to do is
um
Look at GE tracker. We're going to go
look at the Book of law page set what
the selling price is going to be about.
And like I said these don't sell very
quickly, but this is just an example.
Tons of different items out here that
combine like this.
Um well 15 6 8. Yeah, we'll try selling
them for that.
So, if we sell these for 15, 6, 8.
And we'll do 6, 2.
15, 6, 2K.
So, 7, 8, 10.
And we started with 15 mil.
So, 7, 8, 10 plus
7, 3, 9, 1
minus 15 mil. So, about 200 I'm sure
about 200 K in profit and only take us
about
20 minutes or something. It'll take a
while to sell. But either way, you get
the idea. Extremely easy to do. Uh, just
a short list of other items that
combine. Uh, potion decanting, turning
three-dose potions into four-dose
potions.
Um, armor sets.
Oh, we already went through a couple of
these already, but um
Uh, Zamorak dragon headsets, they work
well.
And um
odium wards. Just look up items on the
wiki on the GE tracker. Find items that
have two versions of them. Either they
switch back and forth or they can easily
be manipulated into a different item and
there's often times a margin there. And
that's the point. We're not going to
wait for these to sell cuz it'll take a
while, but you get the idea. And we'll
move on to our next category.
Next up, uh, another category I use for
money making is chests.
Uh, now I know there aren't a ton of
chests, but I thought it would still be
worth men- mentioning. I know some of my
more recent videos I did one on the
sinister chest. I believe if I look down
here, I mean like there are a bunch of
different chests. Um, the one I'm buying
right now are the caskets. Just for fun.
I don't think they'll be like very good
money maker, but let's just open a few
just for fun. Uh, again, I just look at
the wiki. Here you can see all of these.
Well, these are kind of player-owned
house chests. Um, but there are key
chests here. These ones are for
thieving. And there are other ones as
well. Um, but we're just buying some
regular old chests off the Grand
Exchange. And then once I find an item
that I want to buy, so let's go. I have
some in my bank already. Let's just
withdraw an inventory full.
I had to deposit that and look up chest.
What are they called?
Caskets. Sorry, they're caskets. My bad.
I'll withdraw an inventory full.
And what I do is I obviously just go and
look at the loot. So for this we need to
look at the casket.
And then we can see the loot. So we're
buying them for about 1,180 coins each.
Now the loot looks reasonably good.
Almost all of these are worth more than
the casket itself. Only thing we're
going to lose money on are the cosmic
talisman,
uncut emerald, and
a low amount of coins. So let's go ahead
and open these up. Let's just price
check them first. It's just something I
do for fun. And it looks like they are
price checking at about 32.9 mil.
Okay, sorry. And let's start opening
them up. Okay, we got an emerald. That's
profitable. 80 coins, that's not
profitable. Low amount of coins.
Obviously I've never tried this before,
so clearly you get low amounts of coins
commonly. So this probably won't be
worth it. But let's open them up and see
what we get. Got a cosmic talisman. Ooh,
we got a loop half of key.
Ooh, they open up pretty quickly. And
we're just doing this for a video for
later probably, which will be fun.
Clearly the low amount of coin drops is
making this not that profitable. But
let's have a look here.
And oh, we actually did profit. Possibly
just because of this key here, but
anyway, you get the idea. Chest can be
profitable. Just got to look at the
current prices, what you can buy the
keys for, and they're actually a lot of
fun to open I've noticed. Without this
loop half of key
might not have profited
that much, but we wouldn't have lost a
whole lot either. Um I know it's a small
category, but still something worth
looking into.
And last up, something you might want to
look out for is updates. And I know this
gets tossed around a lot, uh but I'm
referring to is uh new item uses or
items being made free to play or new
items being created out of different
things. I'm not talking about flipping
these items so much, but just new money
making opportunities can be created just
by small updates. Let's have a look at
the update list for today.
Uh this just came out like 12 hours ago
or something.
Uh new pin settings, really stoked about
that. Uh grimy herb value increase,
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about. Now FTP energy potions from the
apothecary. Now uh normal energy potions
are no longer a members only item and
you can create them at the apothecary.
Uh let's have a look in the
Hopefully I didn't butcher that spelling
too much. Yeah, we got that nice.
Let's see if the wiki has been updated.
You can make strength potions and yeah,
energy potions if he's given two
limpwurt roots and a chocolate dust.
So now we have the
uh possibility of making kind of a
transformed flip. I wouldn't say that
falls exactly into that category, but
you get the idea. So now you're just
going to have a look at the energy
potion for or is it
energy potion four or energy potion
three? I don't know. Uh energy potion
four, let's hope.
And uh well, it's selling for
about uh 670.
I got a calculator here.
So 670
minus
price of limpwurt roots are 332. So I
don't think it's going to be profitable.
That's 332.
And minus the price of chocolate dust is
170.
So
clearly you're not going to be making
any money off of this, but
you get the idea. Look at the updates,
look at if any items are affected and
then quickly go ahead and just do a
couple calculations. It's a little
confusing at first, but once you get the
hang of it, it's really easy to do. Just
reel through the update log quickly and
you'll find a couple new flips, new
money making ideas, and uh general ideas
for the All right, and last up I know a
lot of you've been waiting for this is
the winner of the bond giveaway from my
bond in 6-hour video
is going to be
140 of you commented, so well done.
Let's go ahead and pick the winner.
Let's see who it's going to be. The
winner is going to be
Arshpreet
Singh. I started playing a long time.
Want to get a bond so that I can make
money and continue the cycle of buying
bonds.
Is the bond will start me
good cuz I'm really poor. Anyways, great
vids and luck good luck for the future.
IGN
Sierra. Anyway.
Congratulations to you. I will get in
touch and we will give away the bond.
Appreciate everyone who left a comment
and the video be on me
forcing to like it. That seemed to be
well received, so I'll do more like that
in the future.
Anyway, hope you enjoyed the video today
and I will see you guys in the next one.